salut à tous le P TR aujourd'hui
nouvelle vidéo avec Wim vous l'avez
reconnu et avec Dani on est de retour
sur le fameux spot où on a trouvé un
coffre fort des cadres et et une
multitude de choses aujourd'hui ce qu'on
va faire c'est qu'on va pêcher à l'ément
mais on va pêcher àément avec des
perches et on va essayer de récupérer
tout ce qu'il y a au fond de l'eau et
qui n'est pas venu quand on a jeté nos
aiments avec la corde Quentin est au
travail mais il va nous rejoindre d'ici
une petite heure donc on va commencer
sans lui et on verra si on arrive à lui
montrer ce qu'on a trouvé bien sûr
n'oubliez pas de vous abonner et de
regarder la chaîne de Wim qui a lancé sa
nouvelle chaîne Youtube et qui fait déjà
de très belles découvertes donc il pêche
surtout au Pays-Bas mais il est aussi
allé en Belgique et il commence à faire
des road trip ici il est en France pour
quelques jours avec Dani un petit
dernier mot à dire en français avant de
commencer last word in
French
ohge regardez
ce la main de fatma donc c'est sûrement
bijou
arabesour bonjour bonourer Qui des
trésorsem à qui les
trésors en fait on utilise des aimentss
puissants au bout d'une perche ou et il
y a de il y a des bouts de voiture on a
fait un coffre fort un coffre fort ouais
parce que ils sont cambriolés et jetés
mais il était vide ouais celi-là était
vide mais des fois il laisse quelques
indices c'est l'aventure ah ouais là
vous rentrez pas votre t dans l'eau
quand même si si lui le fait là-bas mais
pas vous moi j'aime pas trop c'est hein
elle a pas bon goût ah ouais vous êtes
une gang là fa que c'est profond comment
ça ouais on est trois ouais il viennent
c'est ici c'est le c'est plus le Canal
du Midi ou non c'est un autre petit
canal c'est un autre canal ouais là
l'eau rentre dans vos trucs hein ouais
que c'est une bonne douche après ah oui
ah
oui avec Dani du coup on est en train de
faire sous le pont parce que c'est vrai
qu'on avait on avait sorti des coffres
forts ici donc ce qu'on va faire c'est
qu'on va essayer de de voir s'il y avait
pas des choses
dedans il a quand même énormément de
vase wi qui enchaîne les panneaux il
vient de faire un panneau noquil
carnacier c'est vrai qu'il y a pas mal
de poissons ici les pêcheurs seront
contents qu'on a nettoyé tout ça
j'espère là on est sur la partie du pont
qu'on avait déjà fa dans la précédente
vidéo et vous avez bien apprécié donc on
continue cette partie jusqu que qu on
passe de l'autre côté du pont pas mal de
C
je j'espère que c'est
pas
mon
wonderful amazing
wouh yeah Nice Nice
[Musique]
bravo elle est tombée la montre est
tombée un couteau ah Nice il a
retrouvé alors qu'est-ce qu'on a ici ah
oui une
clé dans l'état qu'elle est ça commence
super bien avec la montre elle est
magnifique et un
couteau qui travers
oh un
[Rires]
volant
c'est pas très
[Musique]
agréable
pour travers
ok ce côté là maintenant y av aussi des
coffres for donc ça va
êre
cillou pourquoiir jeté ça qu'est-ce que
c'est c'est un bout de canon
c'est très
bizarre remp de
béton
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sa
oh ok un
cric non pas
Ohm
PNE une plaque
d'immatriculation former
onell
ok une vieille
plaque intéressantality
ok
oh
B
c une
pièce j'ai peut-être quelque chose aussi
enfin
accrocheresser de voir si ça vient
ou là là
ou là là ou là
làin de sortes de ressort
cassére un
sa boutille de vin qui est sortie d'un
coup ah j'ai une pièce
aussi W un Fran
1974 a quelque chose
ou
ok qu'est-ce que c'est que ça
ok une autre
pièce ok ok du franc encore 50 c de Fran
je
pense pas mal le couteau a pris
cher
oh j'ai un
sac
full
Ros
oh yeah
Sten
ok les antivol et
des
mag ok
ok
interes
ok ça d'une voiture ça dit en
commentaire si vous savez et encore du
coup des cintes et des antivol
ok donc je vi de remonter
ça
avec le
triangle pas mal Automotive division
ok
ready shape ok
ok Boxx plastic
box inside OK
pas de chance
no
ok I don't like the shape of it I don't
like the i
think I you know I was
talking
ça coûte super cher ça
W
[Rires]
wtin
Nice som coper c'est bien du cuivre on
voit encore la
bobine stop stop oh
non bon ben là je viens de les rejoindre
sur le spot je suis habillé tout propre
je sais pas si je me change ou si je
viens comme ça tu me conseilles quoi moi
je te conseille de pas venir ça pue
non je rigole va te changer non mais je
pense qu'on va manger d'abord pause Heou
ouais tu as quelque chose une machine à
café j'ai la guitare et la machine à
café Dol
gustoexpressopresso
c'estpressopresso et la guitare repe la
guitare la guitare on l'a reprise
c'était pour c'était pour faire une
story la ST V d'ailleurs si vous l'avez
V vous êtes les
meilleurs un
sacbrella non
c'est ah oui c'est un
paraplui
parluie ah non c'est un sac non
non
ah ça c'est un
antivol BL
BL quelque chose dans le
[Musique]
sac
la
gueule je crois que j'ai un coffre
fortettre ma bouche dans
l'eau
ok j'ai aussi un
sacv
quelque chose de
[Musique]
magnétique
ok une photo
[Musique]
si vous reconnaissez cette
personne
est encore
belle le sud de la France ok donc là le
sac est
vidé magasin et
bureau
la le
chien viens
laiss
une
cassette
cassette ok cassette
cassette une BO boîte de cassette ok
mainant on va passer à l'ouverture du
second sac
ou
après ou làdessus
ouais pas grandchose
non
non il a des trucs un peu
mais ok bon dommage des papiers ça y est
Quentin nous a rejoint et il va tester
la pêche àément j'ai ressti le vieuxc
lequ je p 3 ans donc on va voir ce que
ça donne allez dans l'eau franchement je
suis excité j'ai envie de tester ça pour
ceux qui se le demandent nos pè chez nos
viennent du site de maison de la
détection ils ont toute une gamme d'AIM
complète mais nous en général on
recommande les aimants 360° le terreor
est idéal pour débuter mais aujourd'hui
on pêche avec la gamme d' dessus savoir
l'IM bist et lesment Barbarian on des
forces de 1400 et 1600 kg respectivement
vous avez toutes les infos en
description et le code promo pêcheur de
trésor qui offre 5 % sur toute la
boutique un
crocodile
oh c'est
quoi
ble3 oh oui j'ai eu quelque
chose première une
pince
cool
ok une
pince morceau de
voiture allez tu nous le sors encore une
la deuxième bleue
ouis une genre d'aération je viens de
faire une pièce typiquement pour les
pièces c'est bien comme
technique 1996 5 centimes de franc on a
des clés un porte-clé avec une autre clé
ici
intéressant quelque
chose non
ok plus de
rayp bien
jouéose
intéressant c'est disque de
Free ce qu' vient de trouver une grosse
enceinte vraiment grosse
mag un
ded regardez la moule énorme moule de
rivière
anodon oh non
est un petit elle est
morte on va changer de spot yeah ouais
ok Go
place
ok on va voir si quentin se débrouille
pour arriver en marchant vite
allez
go
oh il a
triché ah il
trop c'est bon je suis là ah la pêche
été bonne he ouais pas
malin il a de quoi faire là nous on
pêche ici quoi ah ouais ce sera ouis
vous perdez des l'UR un peu ou pas non
ouais vous en perdrez moins pas de
voiture et tout c'est quoi ça pêche ça
ouais c'est ça ah ouais d'accord
c'est pas mal félicitations en tout cas
les gars merci c'est tout
malit ça nettoi ouais franchement c'est
gentil au revoir au
revoir regardez les trois les trois h
devant nous on est mieux derrière avec
RAST